how's it going BR my name is
piepie are you ready for
thiscb containment brid remember scpb
right this is pretty much a more
fancy game of it best explanation I know
[Music]
um uh
basically it's like a I don't know how
to it's an alpha that's what I was going
to say I
can't so here we go you're too scared to
watch I'm Never Scared all right here we
go SCP
173 please enter the containment chamber
Oh you mean there oh they're going nice
swag on those guys who what was
that1 all right Jesus Christ who what
the hell is that
hello please approach SCP 173 it looks
too sexy for me I don't know about this
hello hey you there there seems to be a
problem with the door control system uh
the door isn't responding to to close it
please maintain a direct eye contact
with SCP 173 and wait for
further oh no oh no oh no I I'm sorry
I'm sorry I can change I'm out of here
what oh you little
[__]
what happened I died oh
no all right let's skip the intro I
guess all right here we go let's try the
original vers of this cuz I don't really
know what happened there all right this
whoa why is it dark whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa hello oh oh we're
good is that anything is experiencing
multiple keto and ID level contain can't
[__] hear you your mic is like
someone stuck it up someone's
ass all right let's go in
here what is this I don't know what oh
papers I love me some
papers all right what's going on here
all who's there who's there
sh
whoa what is
this
what what oh okay let's go in the Red
Room can we go here hello no it's locked
God damn
it oh that opens the door cool all right
oh that's what the eye is it blinks and
[__] what the hell are you close the
door close the door close the door close
the door all right we're safe we're
safe oh oh are you
there what the
hell what the hell I don't like
this
hello oh movie oh it's that guy who what
the
hell what is
that oh he likes walls at least well I
kind of like walls too actually cuz I'm
standing whoa
who what the [__] where did he go oh
hell oh
no don't be behind me don't be behind
all right let's close this door don't
trust this [__] what is this caution a
time switch closes
door what are you doing
here [__] you I'm sorry I like your
nipples
oh no I died how do I dodge
him you can't really save in this game
yeah it's still in Alpha you can't
really do the save arus and sharo I
think the game is random I don't really
know yet so I think if we go on another
adventure here H it still looks the same
though whoa calm down calm down oh smoke
[__] you smoke you scared me smoke is
scary [__] all right don't just going to
run for it yes yes yes yes yes [__] I
love [__] all right oh they L this
room all
right
shh toilet here come on can I wash my
hands no I love toilets what about the
men's bathroom
hello ah it's the same [__] I don't want
to Blink all right I'm going to follow
the blink radar as the one in the
[Music]
game wait isn't this where I came
from oh hell
no hello Smoke Stop scaring me smoke
you're not cool not cool at all it's all
right it's nothing big here all the
small stuff ah a desk well don't mind if
I do oh what is that a t don't mind if I
what is that a level up you can level up
no way give me all the paper must level
up in this game get strong kill monsters
not the problem ASAS as we do say here
in Sweden
open all right smoke I know you don't
like me but
I no no no where are you going that
makes no sense oh I'm alive I'm alive
it's America thank Satan oh my God are
you still there no no no you're not
supposed to oh I closed him I get it now
why did I go in there all right I got I
got I
[Music]
got
oh [__] that [__] you just popped in my
why do you look so stupid get out of
here stop that nonsense if you oh he
cracked my
neck stupid [__] game I hate you I
hate
pin why what are you looking at what'
you looking at boy uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah ain't got no problem with
this game it keeps crashing it keeps
crashing all right we are here I don't
know where we are oh there's two doors
no no there's one door
who all right it's like a Sav and quick
ship is experiencing multiple cones side
lock down
initiated smoke gives me
blink all right more blood more blood
and pain and Sh that's okay oh cool who
smoke you scare me why do you always
scare me smoke all right only do love
King I'm just going to go here cuz I
don't want to be anywhere else all right
Corridor play nice with me I'm new to
this game what does it say caution all
right that's cool I just want to go out
I need a key card for that
door all right that's
cool hello huh what is this I'll take
you you and you cool yeah that's all
party that's all party ler you're all
invited if you want
to you don't want to come to my party
lame lame o i thr the best part is in
the
universe all right so far I'm not doing
too bad not
too oh you [__] this
game [__] that [__] I will do another
attempt at this when I don't die as I
guess I can play one more just for
funsies I hate that guy I found the key
card is I I don't find the key card and
the door it's always like one of them at
different
times all right here we
go here we go yo shh shh everyone be
quiet hey don't
me what the hell was that Lev W lock
down initi you just ran
past all right cool everything's again
everything's fantastic butterflies
unicorn RB baby steal every all of that
[__] all of that [__] at
once all of that [__] at
once
ah this looks different lamp what's
going down here is that a key card sorry
don't tell anyone I took it whoa whoa
whoa whoo did someone know I took it
let's go in
here all right now let's find a place to
put it have the key card heard someone
behind
me open the door open all right I guess
can't really go there let's try over
here all right whoa what went down here
SCP secur contain and penetrate what I
always live by no you [__] off close the
door I'll see you
later alligator anator
crat later this door has to be able to
open yeah
okay how's it going down here it's all
okay yes let's go to maintenance tunnel
I don't really want to go there but
let's do it anyway there might be good
stuff down here hello
maintenance how y'all doing down here
it's
good all right I'll just go left what is
this don't blink on me no no no no no no
no no no I hear blobbing no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no that's
okay we just go deeper dig deeper in the
tunnel oh oh no no oh no no no no no no
no no no no no it's okay
hello it's okay it's okay it's all okay
just got to be really quiet cuz I don't
know where we are all right it's good
it's good good times good times in the
maintenance to this where it all went
down no it's after me it's after
me oh what the hell was that
hello run
faster you're so slow you're so
slow oh
no it's
co are you still
there I think that's yes I think that's
yes indeed open he's coming
please oh no no no no no no
all right um I think that will have to
be it like and favor if you enjoy
subscribe to come bro today and I'll see
you in next episode that's it don't
waste my time
Woman
kissing kissing him you like that or not
do you like it tell me tell me do you
want the man 12 not K me